A data frame is a particularly good data
structure to represent the contents of
a CSV file.
It's a two-dimensional data
structure with a different type for
each column, which is often
exactly what you want for a CSV.
Pandas has a function called read_csv,
which takes in the file name of a CSV
file and loads it into a data frame.
I'll use this to load in the New York
subway and weather data.
Since there is a lot of data I don't
want to print out the entire data frame
like I've done before.
Instead, I'll use the head function to
print out just the first five lines.
The head function returns
a smaller data frame so
the results display just
like a small data frame.
I can also use the describe function to
see some statistics about each column
like the mean and
the standard deviation.
You got a preview of the read_csv
function at the end of the last lesson.
It was used by the starter code
that loaded in the gap minder
dataset for you.